I look like you I get it I was clean
shaving I had hair you wanna see that
look turn around real quick every day I
get this I get it every day they go hey
a little fluffy and I go I get it full
because I tell that's all I do on my
stuff I tell stories you know I tell
hella stories and everybody always tells
me like you're not fat you're just full
of stories yeah you're me at 28.
yeah is that how old are you 33 okay
pretty much the same man I gotta be
honest and then my wife says like well
he's you on vacation
like yeah I do gotta wear some more fun
shirts I still have that shirt but I
don't have that hair it's okay yeah it
was a good run it was a good run it was
it was a good run
[Applause]